sometimes i'll start a sentence and i
don't even know where it's going i just
hope i find it along the way
like an improv conversation
improvisation i told dwight that there
is honor and losing
which as we all know is completely
ridiculous but there is however
honor in making a loser feel better
which is what i just did for dwight
would i rather be feared or loved
um easy both i want people to be afraid
of how much they love me
my name is michael scott webster's
dictionary
defines wedding as the fusing
of two medals with a hot torch
well you know something i think
you guys are two medals
gold medals
why i'm taking responsibility and it is
up to me
to get rid of the curse that hit
meredith
with my car i'm not superstitious but
i'm i am a little stitious
ryan cost dunder mifflin hundreds of
thousands of dollars michael
ryan david i don't care if ryan murdered
his entire family he is like a son to me
you know what today is
not a good day for a sales contest we're
not we're not doing this
today that doesn't seem fair you want to
talk about fair
does anyone need to smell my old carpet
you explained to me how that was fair
and i'll explain to you how this is fair
plus i just i think that picking today
was sort of taking advantage but you're
the one who picked it i
am a victim of a hate crime
stanley knows what i'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well i
hated it
a lot okay i david here it is
my philosophy is basically this and this
is something that i live by
and i always have and i always will
don't
ever for any reason do
anything to anyone for any reason
ever no matter what no matter
where or who or who you are with
or or where you are going or
or where you've been
ever for any reason whatsoever
david wait no is there no way we can get
rid of him
not without cause michael i have cause
it is because i hate him
you have to get along with toby no yep
i don't goodbye michael
[Music]
i feel like all my kids grew up and then
they married each other
it's every parent's dream dwight
betrayed me once before
so this is his strike two you know what
they say
fool me once strike one but fool me
twice
strike three
i love babies i think they are beautiful
in all sorts of different ways i try to
pick up and hold a baby every day
if possible because it nourishes me
it feeds my soul babies are drawn to me
and i think it's because they see me as
one of them
but cooler and with my life put together
a little bit
if a baby were president there would be
no taxes
there would be no war
there would be no government
and things could get terrible
it actually probably would be a better
screenplay idea than a serious
suggestion
nobody should have to go to work
thinking oh this is the place that i
might die today
that's what a hospital is for an office
is for not dying
unbelievable i do the nicest thing that
anyone's ever done for these people and
they freak out
well happy birthday jesus sorry your
party's so lame
oh no no no no you will not die staley
stanley you will not die
stanley stanley barack is president
you are black sadly when i said before
that i was king of forwards you got to
understand
that i don't come up with this stuff i
just forwarded it along
you wouldn't arrest a guy who's just
delivering drugs from one guy to another
cousin mike what's the very very worst
thing about prison
don't encourage him dwight the worst
thing about prison
was that was the dementors they were
flying all over the place and they were
scary and then they come down and they
suck the soul out of your body and it
hurts
dementors like in harry potter no not
harry potter
there are no movies in prison okay well
a good trick is to pump to the tune of
staying alive by the bee gees do you
know that song
yes yes i do i love that song first i
was afraid i was petrified
no toby is in hr which technically means
he works for corporate
so he's really not a part of our family
also he's divorced so he's really not a
part of his family
ryan wanted michael the subject to uh
explain the computer system the object
to whomever meaning us the indirect
object which is the
the correct usage of the work no one uh
asked you anything
ever so whomever's name is toby why
don't you take a letter opener and stick
it in your skull hey
michael let me make this very easy for
you i could give it
about your happiness stop dating my
mother
you know what i'm gonna start dating her
even harder what's that supposed to mean
you know what it means holly and i are
like romeo and juliet and this office is
like the dragon that kept them apart
if i had a gun with two bullets and i
was in a room with hitler bin laden and
toby i would shoot toby twice
no i am not going to be proposed to in
the break room
that is not going to be our story
should have burned this place down when
i had a chance is there a god
if not what are all these churches for
and who is jesus's dad
guess what i have flaws what are they
oh i don't know i sing in the shower
sometimes i spend too much time
volunteering occasionally i'll hit
somebody with my car
so sue me no don't
sue me that's the opposite of the point
that i'm trying to make
all right come here oh whoa i'm doing
something come on
hello come on i need this come over here
you're talking just sit down
no no no no no no is everything okay yep
yeah what is it like being single
i like it i like
starting each day with a sense of
possibility
and i'm optimistic because every day
i get a little more desperate and
desperate
situations yield the quickest results um
actually i'm sending ryan on a top
secret mission
tell her what it is updating emergency
contacts
well is that really a priority is it a
priority oh i don't know
um what if there's a tornado pam
people's legs are crushed under rubble
please would you be so kind as to call
my wife no
i can't because we don't have any
emergency contact information because
pam said it wasn't a priority
think think with your head pam okay well
that walks out
you